[Music]
you appeared last time on the program
and something occurred during your
appearance yeah that created quite a
stir
on the web yeah the Internet's hilarious
so I stepped off the stage thinking oh
man I was one of the best appearances
you've had about it yeah I thought we
pushed the the product well and I I
thought the audience was engaged and
then I get home and sort of look at the
reviews and number one it says Seth
Green picks nose eats booger and I was
like Scrolls ago they're like disgusting
how could you Seth Green pics knows eats
booger video and I was like uh-oh
is there and then I'll watch the video
and the thing is like you know your own
body you're you're like familiar with
your own experiences enough to say oh
yeah that's something that happened in
my life and so I know for a fact that I
didn't pick my nose and eat the booger
but when you watch the video it's like
that's exactly what it looks like so
okay yeah well first of all let's look
at the neck cover what sort of the
internet coverage
first there was there and bear in mind
this is the web coverage all over the
place there's all this coverage on these
different sites and I was hearing about
it but we're talking about it I mean
that's just that wasn't that was the tip
of the iceberg
there were editorials in the Wall Street
Journal nobody and and and so what we're
gonna do now there was also like it's
you know the stealthy the see how dare
he the balls to try and get this past us
like like I've plotted this or
orchestrated it was really bizarre well
it even will I was gonna say then even
weirder was this whole contingent of
people that were like hey so what I eat
my boogers
that is the internet and that is the
internet photo right away I'm like hey I
don't need you to defend ya you main
ting and I agree that this is not
something that really happened but when
you look at the tape well you see like
me just letting a really embarrassing
series of states take a look and then
you can explain bro
your outfit shows that you've really
evolved over the years because there's a
thing everybody knows about called
called throwback Thursday yeah you can
post pictures of yourself in your early
teens and not too long ago
[Applause]
is that yes I know I know there's a that
looks really bad
yeah I mean let's wait impolite because
you're not supposed to put things in
your mouth with your left
yeah let's break it down because you can
there's a series let's go ahead let's
break it down there you go there's the
pic right there's the pig and then they
transfer the eating right doctors are
still young
the genius now what is your what are you
you're maintaining it's a series of
unfortunate little bears tic that's not
a tic no that was me doing this I'm like
actually rubbing my fingernails together
really embarrass you know it's
embarrassing but I get nervous coming on
television I don't know if anybody
realizes even though I've been doing
this a really long time you still get
like butterflies and then yeah it's hard
to restrict yourself and everybody's a
little like twitchy and stuff so what am
I going to say it's exactly what it
looked like but this is not what
happened you have defended yourself
saying that another that actually a very
well no I didn't faint miss person in
this storm of everyone coming to my
defense which I maintain yeah I don't
need that man I don't need that right
people were like hey check this out the
Pope the Pope picks his boogers and
there's video the Pope yeah you guys
right video I see
I mean I guess I guess you forgot that
that popemobile is not tinted but again
me showing this is only making me sound
guilty the Pope doesn't yeah hey that's
this thing anyone can do Hey look what
the Pope did guys the last thing we
should do is use the Pope as an example
for our own behavior
[Laughter]
you